there is a storm brewing
in the economy and people are just now
starting to talk about it and they're
starting to talk about it because
the eviction moratorium is ending
john went deep in the internet
best business show research team and he
found a statistic
i literally don't believe this but i i
know it's true because he went and found
it and showed it to me
16 of adult renters
are behind on their rent and could be at
risk of eviction
almost one in five adults that rent in
the united states
are behind on their rent and could be
facing eviction
and so when we show this what it shows
is when we look at it
states and cities were given 45 billion
dollars in federal rental assistance
allocated by congress during the
stimulus packages both passed in
december and march
only 3 billion of the 45 billion given
to the states and cities has actually
been given out to people
42 billion of the federal rental
assistance
has not actually made its way into the
hands of the people who need it most
and so when you start to look at that
data according to the us treasury
you can see that nationwide rent prices
are up seven and a half percent so far
this year
three times higher than normal
and california has 45 percent of
households living
in rentals so in some of these states
nearly 50 percent of the population
is renting not owning and so when you
look at let's say july 2021 one bedroom
medium rent prices in all of these
different cities
you can see that in new york city and in
san francisco
the median rental price of a one bedroom
is
twenty seven hundred dollars give or
take you then can look all the way down
you still have
for a one bedroom in miami or santa
santa ana
i think it is yes santa ana uh is about
1800 bucks
and so these prices are very high
imagine moving
to somewhere like san francisco or new
york as a young person
and trying to rent twenty seven hundred
dollar one bedroom apartment that's the
median
price pretty pretty crazy times
and so when we look at the national rent
growth we can see that the growth in
median price
compared to the previous year news flash
it's up it's up a lot there's one
and two bedroom both may 2020 to may of
this year
this is bonkers and so when you start to
see
the growth in these median prices you
can see
six seven eight almost nine percent
growth
in some of these types of rentals and so
what it's showing
is that at the exact same time that
prices are going up
people are falling behind and the
eviction moratorium is ending so we've
got one in seven renters
struggle to pay rent what we've seen is
that this is
struggle so you may actually be up to
date
on your uh rentals but you're
struggling one in seven people and we
know that
one in five are likely to be
behind and so when you see some of these
statistics
it's pretty scary right there's the one
in seven renters struggle to pay rent
uh the percentage of adults whose
household is behind on rent by state
so depending on how you kind of
calculate it one in five one and seven
somewhere in that range
is behind on rent and you can see that
in the
east part of the country there are much
much higher percentages
than in the western part of the country
why
lots and lots of different factors but
definitely
something that ends up being very
obvious then if you go and you look at
lower income americans
they are far more likely to be behind on
rent
obviously than those who are not but
when you actually look at the data
this is pretty scary what you can see is
that less than
25 000 household income
23 percent are likely to be behind
on rent three percent of people who make
over 150 000 are behind on rent that's
still a crazy number right
over 100k four percent of people are
behind on rent
when they said spend less than you make
they thought just like oh just don't pay
rent
well the uh one of the interesting stats
i heard was that 40 there was like 46
uh yeah in 46 and a half billion in
rental relief previously approved by
congress but only three billion of it
went
distributed work to actual renters yeah
we know did you just say that yeah no i
didn't hear that yeah
you were you were googling you were a
researcher
uh when we were looking at those top
cities uh it's funny because five of the
top ten were in california and 45
percent of california's rent it's the
number one highest
most expensive rental state so 45
percent of californians rent
and 50 and it's got the
five of the top 10 highest rents in the
country it ranks number one as the most
expensive rental market you know what
that means right
get the hell out of california yeah but
no california and new york are extending
the program
so individual states can still so
individual states but the federal
federal eviction is over it's up it
ended uh and then individual states can
go and place their own rules new york
and california chose to do so
12 of people who make over 50k a year
are behind on rent that's a lot
12 percent that is a double-digit
percentage of americans that make over
50 thousand dollars
a year i remember seeing it behind on
rent it was uh it was rents over the
past like three to four years and it
essentially got you know lighter colors
one way all the way to darker
and it was the top 100 cities in the
country and essentially
every city at the end currently was
about as red as it could get on the
chart which essentially means that
prices have gone up dramatically across
basically every single uh popular city
throughout the country
i'm not a uh a mathematician so and i
don't want to do public math so i'm just
googling here
not google and i'm calculating here if
you pay 2 800
which was the median rent price in san
francisco in new york
uh a year that's 33 600 3
600 if you get paid 50 000 a year
you don't even after taxes have enough
money to pay rent
for the most part oh and then we want
you to save 500 to a thousand dollars a
year for
uh for your student loans no no no for
your student loans oh well yeah
everything
so if you're if the average student loan
payment
on a monthly basis is 500 bucks and then
you've got 2 800
uh is the median price in san francisco
or new york where most
young people want to go work at the
companies that are there then what
you're looking at is 2 800
plus 500 i see this look this is a great
one you got calculators 3 300
times 12 that's 39 600
which means that literally before you
pay taxes you only have 11 000
to live on doesn't even include
after tax this brings me back to one
thing that you said a few months ago
that really stuck in my mind when
it's harder for the average american to
save
300 a month than it might be to go make
an
extra 300 a month oh that's a fact for
sure the whole idea is
every personal finance person in the
world will tell you hey
you want to be rich here's what you
should do you should spend less money
right and so let's say that your budget
on a monthly basis
is 2 500 right and that 2500
we're gonna try to convince you that you
should spend
500 less okay so we're going to reduce
your monthly expenses by 20
if you're only spending 2500 a month and
they say to you you should spend 500
less there's zero percent chance you're
figuring it out zero zero
this is not happening gas transportation
rent and food done you ain't doing it in
most cities in america
so if they want you to do that you
literally can't do it but even if you
could figure out how to do it
you would live in a really shitty place
a miserable life and likely would be put
in a situation
where you're actually unhappy right
because of all the sacrifices you'd have
to do
to reduce your 2500 monthly expenses by
20
people do it but would it be simpler
for you to figure out how to make 500
more
per month i think yes in that specific
scenario
in most cities around the country it
depends do you have kids
are you married are you a single mom
what do you work two jobs one job like
there's a lot that goes into it
but for the average person i think it
would be easier to figure out how to
make an extra five hundred
than it would be to cut 20 percent of a
2500
a month budget and so when you look at
that scenario
maybe the numbers aren't exactly a
perfect trade-off maybe it's make 300
more a month or try to save 500. maybe
you do a little bit of both maybe you
can save 200 and you can go figure out
how to make 300 right
all these different components but i do
think that the conversation around
personal finance is so one-sided
around save spend less cut your expenses
try to spend 100 less a month like all
the stuff but one of the best ways that
you can put yourself in a better
financial position
is to go figure out how to make more
money and that may include getting a
second job it may include doing some
sort of
side hustle that may include literally
selling things on the internet uh
creating value
in your community all kinds of different
options but in 2021
trying to figure out how to make 300 to
500 extra a month
there are ways to do it and you can do
it from your own home with the internet
or you can go and exchange your time for
money not ideal but if you need the
money you can go figure out how to do it
so i think that you've just got to stay
open-minded it's not all about just
spending less
also you've got to figure out how to
make more money and if you put those two
things together that's the holy grail
spend less and make more then obviously
you can get to your financial goals much
faster